is League of Legends easier than DOTA
how that I think about it and one of the
donation goal was that I would install
league and play a league game which we
reached I was I was being coached by a
French known league coach okay the guy
abandoned he R rage quit the game six
minutes
in I used play DotA Allstars really
seriously in high school and then I have
like 6 and a2k hours in Dota 2 and I
came back to League bro it's so easy by
comparison bro imagine your first ever
time playing League of Legends and you
have to play against Seb and he's
playing
[Music]
Darius league is a fun game all right
I'll admit it league is a fun game I
play it for fun but it is absolutely
DOTA for babies if you're a league
player and you go to DOTA you're going
to be clueless you're have no idea what
to do if you're a DOTA player and you
come to League you're going to on
every other like person who's also
learning the game